um and Judd is like this jet is very
shut out who I was on the phone with
today and he said I said I'm going to
get my way to do your podcast and he
said please tell him hello please tell
me look he's a sweeter I really want to
tell him tell him I said um
you know if you could quit to promote
the bubble that would be great yeah that
was that was a terrible gem but it was
fine it was fine it was fine yes I liked
it and I loved Jen he was a great guest
and he's very gay but he's literally one
of my best friends that I'm saying that
fully aware of how weird that is you
created a show crashing he directed it
he believed in you you created friends
yeah you direct the pilot you're you're
the co-creator co-creator yeah perhaps
and it was and I say this to compliment
him it was his show a lot of things my
life did not win like I couldn't Trump
and go like but that's not what happened
Judd would be like like there's a great
example of Judd's genius really I'm done
kissing his ass you'd know if I was
kissing his ass I mean it you know what
I mean right there's a way where you're
like it's genius please call me back you
know it's not that right it's just a
good example I feel like I didn't need
to step that out
there was a scene where I worked at this
place called the Boston Common Club I
really did and we rebuilt it for the for
the um for HBO crashing why I say HBO
and it was an exact replica of this club
that used to exist in New York it was
crazy wow Sarah Silverman walked on and
she started crying we were doing that
all the time we rebuilt rafifi Eugene
Merman and Bobby Tisdale walked on Bobby
started crying like it was just like
imagine if the place you grew up doing
comes rebuilt was torn down and then we
rebuilt it and then we shot scenes
pretending it was still like it was very
emotional but we did the scene
where I was I grew up religious so like
when I started doing comedy I was very
clean
um and I like that all my heroes were
Seinfeld Ray Romano Ellen Gallagher I
actually liked Galaxy I did too okay
Gallagher's mad as hell Gallagher's mad
and I'm sorry that was from a special
buddy if I knew it
would be doing a two-part round right
now three that's up to Rye yep
um but
I I had scripted it a little bit in my
favor meaning the episode was my parents
are in town and they unannounced decide
to show up at the Boston Comedy Club to
watch me this never happened but had it
happened
I would have been the only clean one the
Boston was it was a den of Thieves it
was Pirates it was like
it was crazy right and I was like Jack
McBrayer just like the sweet my parents
come everyone's doing like we the whole
point was people are doing like jizz
jokes and stuff like that they're real
dirty really dirty and you're the only
clean guy and then I go up and I wanted
it to end on this happy note that my mom
is like oh Petey sweetie that was
tremendous everyone else was filth but
you're my golden child why she misses
Doubtfire I don't know but um my mom
sort of talked like that she's
Lithuanian she's Lithuanian but she
talks a little bit like that in like
Boston too but anyway
and then Judd was like he really taught
me something and this is really you ever
give something some somebody something
your therapist told you and you're like
this cost me ten thousand dollars I'm
telling you what to do this is like ten
thousand dollars worth of Show Business
advice right because he was like and
he's so right
uh entertainment's all about surprise
everyone thinks your parents are gonna
like you and not like the dirty people
he was like your mom should be like at
least they had something to say like you
were up there talking about road signs
oh my God it's this satisfying moment
right and it's such a simple principle
but that's one of the that's really ten
thousand dollars worth of appetite right
there